[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: Hi, I'm Nikita.
I'm a Google Cloud
developer advocate.
If you're anything
like me, when you
start working on a new
machine learning problem,
the first place you
go is a notebook.
Maybe you like running
Jupyter in a local environment
or using a Kaggle Kernel, or
my personal favorite, Colab.
With tools like this,
as well as repositories
for pre-trained models
such as TensorFlow Hub,
creating and experimenting
with machine learning
is becoming
increasingly accessible.
But while experimentation
in notebooks is great,
it's easy to hit a
wall when it comes time
to elevate those experiments
up to enterprise scale.
For example, what if you
have a long running job,
want to do distributed
training, host a model
for online predictions,
or maybe your use case
requires more
granular permissions
around security
and data privacy?
Making applications or
training large models
requires additional
tooling to help you scale
beyond just code in a notebook.
But that process can feel
a little bit daunting.
There are so many different
cloud Services and products.
And honestly, it's a little
hard to know where to start.
So today, I'm going
to show you how
to become a cloud machine
learning developer
in just five steps.
We're going to take some
code in a Colab notebook
and then make it production
ready by training and deploying
a model on Google Cloud.
If you're new to Colab, it's a
hosted Jupyter Notebook service
that requires no setup to use,
works entirely in the browser,
and provides free access to
computing resources, including
GPUs.
To train and deploy
our model, we'll
be using Vertex AI, which is
Google Cloud's managed machine
learning platform.
There are a lot of
different products.
But today, we'll be focusing
on training, predictions,
and Workbench, which is the
hosted notebook service.
So here are the five
steps we'll take.
First, we'll create
a managed notebook
instance on Google Cloud.
We'll use Vertex AI Workbench
to create this notebook.
Next, we're going to download
our Colab notebook as a .ipynb
file, and then upload this
file to our Vertex AI Workbench
notebook.
Then we'll launch an execution
of our notebook, which
means that the notebook
will be run cell
by cell in the cloud on the
Vertex AI managed training
service.
We won't need to manually
execute the cells.
Next, we'll deploy the
model to an endpoint.
And finally, we'll
use this endpoint
to get some predictions.
Because why go to
all this effort
if we can't use the model to
actually do something, right?
So let's jump over to a demo.
And I'll show you how
all of this works.
Here's a Colab notebook
with some code.
We're going to train
an image classification
model using TensorFlow on
the deep weeds data set.
This data set contains images
of various weed species
local to pastoral grasslands.
So first in this
notebook, we are
going to import some libraries.
Then we'll download the data
from TensorFlow data sets.
And we can print out all of
the labels in our data set.
We'll do a little preprocessing,
just to scale the data
and split it into training
and validation sets.
And then we can
take a look at some
of the examples in our data set.
Looks like we've
got lantana here
in the top left,
snake weed, a plant
called rubber vine, et cetera.
Now, the next step is
to create our model.
And instead of writing a
model totally from scratch,
I decided to use
TensorFlow Hub, which
is a repository of trained
machine learning models.
TensorFlow Hub provides
feature vectors,
which are pretrained models
without the top classification
layer.
We can use these feature
vectors for transfer learning.
So in the code here,
the first thing we do
is create a feature extractor
from a resnet model.
Then we add a
classification layer on top
with the number of
classes in our data set,
which is what we'll train
on our deep weeds data set.
Lastly, we compile
and train the model.
If you're not very familiar
with TensorFlow or Keras,
don't worry about it.
All you need to know is
that we have some code here
that creates and trains
a machine learning model.
And we could have
just as easily been
using scikit-learn, or
any other machine learning
framework you prefer.
Now, our goal is to
take all of this code
and run it on Google Cloud,
making use of more performant
hardware, and then deploy
the resulting model.
The first thing we need to do is
create our Vertex AI Workbench
notebook.
I'm in the Vertex AI section
of the Google Cloud Console.
And from here, we'll
select Workbench.
Then we'll click on Manage
Notebooks in the top
and select New Notebook.
The first step is to
give the notebook a name.
Then under the
Advanced Settings,
you can customize your notebook
by providing your own Docker
image, changing the hardware
profile, and adding GPUs.
And you can see here that there
are lots of different hardware
options to choose from.
But we'll just stick to
all the defaults for now.
And I'll scroll down
and click Create.
This will take about
a minute or so.
But once this
notebook is created,
we can open it up and
follow the steps in the UI
to authenticate.
So that completes
our first step.
We have now set up our notebook
environment on Google Cloud.
Next, we're going to download
the Colab notebook as a .ipynb
file and then upload it to our
Vertex AI Workbench managed
notebook.
We can open this notebook
and select the TensorFlow 2
kernel, since we're using
TensorFlow for this example.
But note that there are
multiple kernels to choose from,
if you're working with
a different framework.
Now, we want to make
sure that our trained
model is safe to Cloud Storage.
That way we can access it later
for deployment and predictions.
When we launch our training
job on Google Cloud,
it's going to run on a
machine we won't have access
to after the job completes.
So we don't want to save
our model to a local path.
Instead, we want it to be
a path in Cloud Storage.
So I'll scroll down
to the end of our code
here, where we have
the model.save.
And we're going to go ahead
and update this model.save path
to a Cloud Storage bucket.
Now while we could run
the cells of our notebook
manually, for models that
take a long time to train,
a notebook isn't always
the most convenient option.
And if you're building
an application
with machine learning,
it's unlikely
that you'll only need to
train your model once.
Over time, you'll want
to retrain your model
to make sure it
stays fresh and keeps
producing valuable results.
Manually executing the
cells of your notebook
might be the right
option when you're
getting started with a new
machine learning problem.
But when you want to
automate experimentation
at a large scale
or retrain models
for a production application,
a serverless ML training option
will make things much easier.
So instead, we'll use the
notebook execution feature,
which will run our notebook
cell by cell on the Vertex
AI managed training service.
We'll click on the
Execution button up here.
And we'll give our execution
a name and select a GPU.
We're using a more
performant GPU,
so our model will train even
faster than it did in Colab.
Next, we select the
TensorFlow 2.7 GPU image.
This container comes
pre-installed with TensorFlow
and many other data
science libraries.
And we don't have to worry
about installing GPU drivers.
Then we launch the execution.
Back in the console,
we can track
the progress of our training
job in the Executions tab.
And this will take
some time to complete.
But once the
training is finished,
we'll be able to see the saved
model artifacts that we stored
in our cloud storage bucket.
Of course, machine learning is
not just about training models.
Now that we have
a trained model,
the next step is to deploy it
so that we can use this model
to get predictions.
Back on our notebook,
I'm going to paste in
this additional cell here, which
will use the Vertex AI Python
SDK to deploy the
model we just trained.
Deploying the model to
an endpoint associates
the save model artifacts
with physical resources
for low latency predictions.
This will also
take a few minutes.
But when the
deployment finishes,
we can see our model
and our endpoint
over here in the console.
So our last step is
to get predictions
with our newly deployed model.
I've gone ahead and uploaded
some test images to this folder
here in our notebook instance.
And I have this
notebook that I've also
uploaded that I wrote
called Predict, which
will do a little
pre-processing on these images,
and then make a prediction
request to our endpoint.
So we can use the Vertex
AI Python SDK again
to get predictions
for these images.
So let's see what
we've got here.
Here's the image.
And it's generating
the prediction.
And we can execute a
few more of these cells
and just see what happens.
Now, I thought it would be
interesting to actually test
out an image of my own.
I've recently been working
on starting a vegetable
garden in my backyard.
And in addition to dealing
with squirrels and butterflies
and rabbits that keep
trying to eat up my tomatoes
and blackberries, I
have to figure out
how to get rid of the weeds
that keep growing in my beds.
And there's a plant
that keeps popping up.
And I wanted to
know what it was.
So I went ahead and uploaded
an image from my garden
as well, just to see if
we could identify it.
And it looks like I might
have a species called rubber
vine appearing in my garden.
The steps we took today were
to create a Vertex AI Workbench
managed notebook,
upload our .ipynb file,
launch a notebook execution,
deploy the model, and lastly,
get predictions from that model.
With this framework
in mind, I hope
you start thinking
about how you can
build your own machine learning
applications with Vertex AI.
There are tons of other features
in Vertex AI to explore.
And if you want some
more hands-on experience,
be sure to check
out these code labs.
If you build something
interesting with Vertex
AI and notebooks,
definitely let me know.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]